[Music]
over the past year I've been working on
a book project called LGBTQ stats I
co-authored it with David Deschamps who
is my husband and partner on various
film projects and other book projects
and the idea was to take existing
research from studies polls surveys
websites reports and synthesize it we
looked at probably about a thousand
different existing publications and took
the numbers from those publications and
turned them into a book organized in 16
chapters and a question-and-answer
format sort of a Harper's index style
with a with the goal of making it as
accessible and lively and eye-opening
for anybody who cares about equality or
social justice in America you know it's
it's a great tool I think for
researchers and academics but also for
folks who just want to know you know how
many people are married in America or
what's the size of the transgender
population or what's the movie with the
biggest LGBT grossing box-office theme
so in terms of surprises there were apps
you know I thought I knew a lot going
into this project but there were some
major eye-opening moments for me
one of the biggest I think was this
question of how many people define
themselves or identify themselves as not
100% heterosexual which is different
than saying I'm gay or lesbian or
bisexual but it's fascinating to see the
growing numbers of young people
particularly in the 18 to 29 year old
demographic who say that they are not a
hundred percent heterosexual and the
number on that is 31 percent so 31
percent of 18 to 29 year olds identify
themselves as not 100% heterosexual
that's I openin to me when you look at
geography and the question of where do
LGB
TQ folks live one of the most
eye-opening details that we came across
was the state that has the highest
percentage of same-sex couples raising
children turns out to be Mississippi or
26% one in four same-sex couples is
actually raising children as as you
notice the book has indeed called LGBTQ
stats and David and I who both identify
as gay man but really wanted to make the
book as inclusive as possible to cover
the full spectrum of LGBTQ and Q
Americans and even beyond America and so
there's there our stats threaded
throughout the 16 chapters that reflect
bisexual and transgender experiences but
there are also separate chapters on
bisexuality and on transgender issues
within the book one basic starting point
is when you look at folks who identify
as lesbian gay or bisexual the majority
actually 52% of that population are
bisexual and so while it's often an
afterthought and I think unfortunately
it's often an afterthought the
experiences of bisexual people are
incredibly central to this community and
to the struggle for both legal
acceptance and I think acceptance within
and among other gay and lesbian and
transgender folks there's there's
certainly a stigma and that's reflected
in the numbers too when you look at like
health disparities between lesbian and
gay people on the one hand and bisexual
people on the other hand there are
numbers and statistics that would
suggest that bisexual people face
additional stress and additional health
risks I think because of the stigma that
is attached by various facets of society
to being bisexual so I think that's and
when you look at media portrayals -
there's been certainly strong progress
for gay and lesbian characters and
medium strong progress for transgender
characters I think the bisexual
representation is lagging and GLAAD has
done you know surveys the document
specifically the numbers for each of
these categories but I think it's fair
to say that there's a lot of room for
more positive and more diverse or trails
of bisexual folks